Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
If we study the laws of fluid motion and implement
them in a computer program, we can create
and enjoy these beautiful fluid simulations.
And not only that, but today, with the amazing
progress in computer graphics research, we
can even enrich our physics simulations with
anisotropic damage and elasticity.
So what does that mean exactly?
This means that we can simulate more extreme
topological changes in these virtual objects.
This leads to better material separation when
the damage happens.
So it appears that today we can do a great
deal, but these techniques are pretty complex,
and take quite a while to compute, and they
typically run on your processor.
That’s a pity, because many powerful consumer
computers also have a graphics card, and if
we could restate some of these algorithms
to be able to run them on those, they would
run significantly faster.
So, do we have any hope for that?
Well, today’s paper promises a new particle
data structure that is better suited for number
crunching on the graphics card, and is, hence,
much faster than its predecessors.
As a result, this runs the Material Point
Method, the algorithm that is capable of simulating
these wondrous things you are seeing here,
not only on your graphics card, but the work
on one problem can be also be distributed
between many-many graphics cards.
This means that we get crushing concrete,
falling soil, candy bowls, sand armadillos,
oh my!
You name it.
And all this, much faster than before.
Now, since these are some devilishly detailed
simulations, please do not expect several
frames per second kind of performance, we
are still in the seconds per frame region,
but we are not that far away.
For instance, hold on to your papers because
this candy bowl example contains nearly 23
million particles, and despite that, it runs
in about 4 seconds per frame on a system equipped
with four graphics cards.
Four seconds per frame!
My goodness!
If somebody told this to me today without
showing me this paper, I would have not believed
a word of it.
But there is more.
You know what, let’s double the number of
particles and pull up this dam break scene.
What you see here is 48 million particles
that runs in 15 seconds per frame.
Let’s do even more.
These sand armadillos contain a total of 55
million particles, and take about 30 seconds
per frame.
And in return, look at that beautiful mixture
of the two sand materials.
And with half a minute per frame, that’s
a great deal, I’ll take this any day of
the week.
And if we wish to simulate crushing this piece
of concrete with a hydraulic press, that will
take nearly a hundred million particles.
Just look at that footage.
This is an obscene amount of detail.
And the price to be paid for this is nearly
four minutes of simulation time for every
frame that you see on the screen here.
Four minutes you say?
Hmm, that’s a little more than expected.
Why is that?
We had several seconds per frame for the others,
not minutes per frame.
Well, it is because the particle count matters
a great deal, but that’s not the only consideration
for such a simulation.
For instance, here, you see with delta t something
that we call time step size.
The smaller this number is, the tinier the
time steps with which we can advance the simulation
when computing every interaction, and hence,
the more steps there are to compute.
In simpler words, generally, time step size
is also an important factor in the computation
time, and the smaller this is, the slower
the simulation will be.
As you see, we have to simulate 5 times more
time steps to make sure that we don’t miss
any particle interactions, and hence, this
takes much longer.
Now, this one appears to be perhaps the simplest
simulation of the bunch, isn’t it?
No, no, no.
Quite the opposite!
If you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now squeeze that paper, because, and
watch carefully.
They wiggle.
They… wiggle!
Why do they wiggle?
These are just around 6 thousand bombs, which
is not a lot, however, wait a minute…each
bomb is a collection of particles, giving
us a total of not a measly 6 thousand, but,
a whopping 134 million particle simulation,
and hence, we may think that it’s nearly
impossible to perform in a reasonable amount
of time.
The time steps are not that far apart for
this one, so we can do it in less than one
minute per frame.
This was nearly impossible when I started
my PhD, and today, less than a minute for
one frame.
It truly feels like we are living in a science
fiction world.
What a time to be alive!
I also couldn’t resist creating a slow-motion
version of some of these videos, so if this
is something that you wish to see, make sure
to visit our Instagram page in the video description
for more.
Thanks for watching and for
your generous support, and I'll see you next
time!